one of our roots to helping people free
their mind is to describe techniques
that are used in propaganda so one there
is salience when some very novel
information is presented to you like a
big number you take notice so you'll
you'll recall that there were predicted
temperatures we've been told that
temperatures will get up to 48. then it
doesn't matter if the temperature gets
up to 48 or not the numbers gone into
your head to an extent it's hard I think
these days for people not to be
conspiracy theorists and inverted commas
when there are all these forest fires
that
politicians say this is undeniably
caused by click change and then a week
later the involvement of arsonists is
admitted but because there's a kind of a
truthiness effect from photographs and
videos that affect you emotionally much
more than just the written word which is
why one of our items advice in the book
is to read information rather than watch
videos if you want more dispassionately
absorb and analyze the information